ANDREW BACEVICH: The
aim of the book is
really quite simple.
It invites Americans to consider
the possibility that
we have, as a nation, fallen
prey to a set of attitudes
toward war, soldiers, and
military institutions that
constitute a variant
of militarism.
The book explains the origins
of this new American
militarism, new in the sense
that these attitudes emerged
relatively recently in the
decades following Vietnam.
And it suggests that this
emphasis on force is at odds
both with our interests and with
our founding traditions.
And it offers some ideas for
how to restore a sense of
balance and realism to
US military policy.
This the second time today
I gave this talk.
I gave it this morning at the
Carnegie Council, where the
average age was at least 70,
and everybody wore a tie.
And I notice that I'm the only
person here who wears a tie.
And, I dare say, I'm the oldest
person in the room.
And the other thing I
was struck by as I
was waiting to start.
You're all sitting there
looking at some kind of
electronic sort of gizmo.
And I realized to myself, even
you are using your smartphone
to do the introduction,
and here I am reading
my text off of paper.
And how that just must mark me
as such a Neanderthal from a
different universe,
so bear with me.
But let me make a point, early
on, emphasizing some of the
things that my book is not.
It's not an expression
of anti-Americanism.
It's not an attack
on soldiers.
I hold the American soldier
in very high regard.
As Will suggested, I was once
myself an American soldier.
And the book certainly is
not a pacifist tract.
Humankind, I believe, is
condemned to live in a world
in which political competition
will never end, and in which
force will always have
a place, whether
we like it or not.
And indeed, to some degree, our
hopes of achieving even a
modicum of stability and justice
probably will require
us to employ force from
time to time.
But my key point of the book is
this, that somewhere, right
around the end of the Cold War,
Americans generally said
yes to military power.
If you want to pick a very
specific moment when this
occurred, that moment might be
early in 1991, when Operation
Desert Storm ended, in what
appeared at the time to be a
historic victory.
Right then, in 1991, the
skepticism about arms and
armies that had informed the
American experiment from its
founding pretty much vanished.
Political leaders, liberals and
conservatives alike became
enamored with military might.
And American military leaders,
who ought to have known
better, became complicit in
marketing alluring visions of
future warfare that had no
basis in history and that
events soon revealed
as fraudulent.
The ensuing affair has been
a passion pursued in utter
disregard of the consequences
that have ensued.
Few of those wielding authority
in Washington or
influencing opinion in the
mainstream media have
critically evaluated the
implications of valuing
military power for
its own sake.
Fewer still have considered
the possibility that
cultivating permanent global
military superiority might be
at odds both with American
principles and
with American interests.
Now how does this new American
militarism, defined as
outsized expectations regarding
the efficacy of
force, a tendency to see
military power as the truest
measure of national greatness,
and a romanticized view of
soldiers, how does
this new American
militarism manifest itself?
Well, it does so, first of all,
in the scope, cost, and
configuration of America's
present day military
establishment.
Recall that through the first
two decades of US history,
political leaders in Washington
gauged the size and
capabilities of America's armed
forces according to the
security tasks immediately
at hand.
A grave and proximate threat
to the nation's well-being
might require a large and
powerful military
establishment.
But, in the absence of such a
threat, policymakers scaled
down that establishment
accordingly.
With the passing of crisis, in
other words, the army raised
up for the crisis immediately
went away.
This had been the
case in 1865.
It was the case in 1918.
It was the case again in 1945.
The general principle was to
maintain the minimum force
required and no more.
Since the end of the Cold War,
however, having come to value
military power for its own sake,
the United States has
abandoned this principle and is
committed, as a matter of
policy, to maintaining military
capabilities far in
excess of those of any would
be adversary or even
combination of adversaries.
This commitment finds both
qualitative and quantitative
expression with the US Armed
Forces dwarfing those of even
America's closest ally.
Thus, whereas the United States
Navy maintains and
operates about a dozen large
attack aircraft carriers, the
ones flaunted Royal
Navy has none.
Indeed, there is, in all the
battle fleets of the world, no
ship even remotely comparable
to a Nimitz class carrier.
Today, the United States Marine
Corps possesses more
attack aircraft then does the
entire Royal Air Force.
And the United States has two
other even larger air forces,
one an integral part of the
Navy, and the other officially
designated as the United
States Air Force.
Indeed, in terms of numbers of
men and women in uniform, the
United States Marine Corps is
half again as large as the
entire British army.
And the Pentagon has a second
even larger army, actually
called the United States Army,
which, by the way, operates
its own air force of several
thousand aircraft.
All of these massive
and redundant
capabilities cost money.
Prior to 9/11, American military
spending exceeded, by
a factor of 25 the combined
military budgets of the seven
rogue states then comprising
the roster of US enemies.
Indeed, by some calculations,
the United States was then
spending more on its armed
forces than every other nation
in the world combined.
This was a circumstance without
historical precedent.
The effect of 9/11 was to
increase Pentagon spending by
leaps and bounds.
In 2001, the base defense budget
totalled $287 billion.
The budget request released by
the Pentagon last week, styled
as an austerity measure, comes
in at a tidy $527 billion, not
quite double what
it was in 2001.
And oh, did I not mention that
the base budget excludes the
cost of actually waging
ongoing wars.
That was $159 billion
last year.
And it also excludes
veterans benefits.
That was $127 billion
last year.
Add those to the tab and annual
US military outlays at
present reach somewhere
around $750 billion.
In constant dollars, the
Pentagon today, spending is
considerably higher than
it was at any time
during the Cold War.
That is to say, back when we
worried about having to fight
the communist hordes.
More astonishingly still, after
the war in Afghanistan
ends, if it ends at the end of
2014, projected Pentagon
spending will still remain at
levels higher than reached at
any time during the Cold War.
On a day-to-day basis, what are
these forces exist to do?
Well, simply put, for the
Department of Defense,
defense, per se, figures
as little more than an
afterthought.
The primary mission of America's
far flung military
establishment is global power
projection, a reality tacitly
understood in all corners
of American society.
That well over a decade after
the collapse of the Soviet
Union, the United States
continues to maintain bases
and military forces in several
dozen countries--
by some counts well over
100 countries--
rouses minimal controversy
despite the fact that many of
these countries are perfectly
capable of providing for their
own security needs.
That even apart from fighting
wars and pursuing terrorists,
US forces--
these days augmented by
CIA paramilitaries and
profit-minded private security
contractors--
are constantly prowling around
the globe, training,
exercising, planning, posturing,
and liquidating
whoever the White House
decides needs to be
liquidated, this elicits no more
notice from the average
American then the presence of a
cop on a city street corner.
Even before the Pentagon
officially assigned itself the
mission of quote unquote
"shaping" the international
environment, members of the
political elite-- and again I
would emphasize liberals and
conservatives alike--
had reached a common
understanding that scattering
US forces around the globe to
restrain, inspire, influence,
persuade, or cajole
paid dividends.
The indisputable fact of global
US military preeminence
also affects the collective
mindset of the officer corps.
For the armed services,
dominance constitutes a
baseline or a point of departure
from which to scale
the heights of ever greater
capabilities.
Indeed, the services have come
to view outright supremacy as
merely adequate and any
hesitation in efforts to
increase the margin of supremacy
as evidence of
falling behind.
The new American militarism also
manifests itself through
an increased propensity to use
force, leading in effect to
the normalization of war.
As a consequence, self-restraint
regarding the
use of force has all
but disappeared.
Whereas, during the entire Cold
War era, several decades,
large-scale US military actions
abroad totalled a
scant six in number.
Since the fall of the Berlin
Wall, they have become almost
annual events.
The brief period extending
from 1989's
Operation Just Cause--
that was the overthrow of
Panama's Manuel Noriega--
to the invasion of Iraq in
2003, featured nine major
military interventions.
And that count of nine does not
include innumerable lesser
actions, such as Bill Clinton's
signature cruise
missile attacks against obscure
targets in obscure
places, the almost daily bombing
of Iraq throughout the
late 1990s, or the quasi-combat
missions that
have seen GIs dispatched, in
recent years, to Rwanda,
Columbia, East Timor, the
Philippines, Pakistan, Libya,
and, most recently, in
various countries
in sub-Saharan Africa.
As crisis has become a seemingly
permanent condition,
so too did war.
The George W. Bush
administration tacitly
acknowledged as much in
describing the global campaign
against terror as a conflict
likely to last decades and
then promulgating a doctrine
of preventive war.
The Obama administration has
abandoned the phrase "global
war on terrorism." But it has
sustained the expectation of
open-ended conflict.
The Iraq war has ended.
The Afghanistan war
is winding down.
But the pursuit of violent
Islamists continues with no
end in sight.
After the Cold War, policy
makers increasingly came to
see coercion as a sort
of all-purpose tool.
Among American War planners, the
assumption has now taken
root that whenever and wherever
US forces next engage
in hostilities, it will be the
result of the United States
consciously choosing
to launch a war.
I was struck the other day.
I think it was either
Saturday or Sunday.
It was an op-ed published in
the New York Times by a
historian at the University of
Texas by the name of Jeremi
Suri calling for preventive
war against North Korea.
And I was struck by that,
because I was puzzled by who
it is, at the Times op-ed pages,
that is sitting there
reviewing manuscripts and
saying, yes indeed, this is
what the American people
need to hear today.
Let's opt for yet another
war before the last
one has wound down.
As President George W. Bush
remarked, the big lesson of
9/11 was that quote, "This
country must go on the offense
and stay on the offense." The
American public's ready
acceptance of the prospect of
war without foreseeable end
and of a policy that abandons
even the pretense of the
United States fighting
defensively or viewing war as
a last resort shows clearly
how far the process of
militarization has advanced.
Now reinforcing this heightened
predilection for
arms was the appearance in the
latter part of the 20th
century of a new aesthetic
of war.
This was the third indication
of advancing militarism.
The old 20th century aesthetic
of armed conflict is
barbarism, brutality, ugliness,
and sheer waste.
It grew out of World War I. It
was depicted by writers such
as Ernest Hemingway
and Robert Graves.
World War II, Korea, and
Vietnam reaffirmed that
aesthetic, in the latter case
with films like Apocalypse
Now, Platoon, and Full
Metal Jacket.
The intersection of art
and war gave birth
to two large truths.
The first was that the modern
battlefield was a
slaughterhouse and modern war,
an orgy of destruction that
devoured the guilty and
the innocent alike.
The second truth, stemming
from the first, was that
military service was an
inherently degrading
experience and military
institutions, by their very
nature, repressive
and inhumane.
But by the turn of the 21st
century, a new image of war
had emerged.
According to many observers,
the era of mass armies and
mechanized warfare had ended .
A new era of high tech warfare
waged by highly skilled
professionals equipped with
smart weapons, as they were
called, had supposedly
commenced.
Describing the result
inspired a new
lexicon of military terms.
War was becoming surgical,
frictionless, postmodern, and
even abstract or virtual.
It was now called coercive
diplomacy.
The object of the exercise
no longer
to kill but to persuade.
According to Michael Ignatieff,
fighting no longer
implied the prospect of dying
for some abstract cause since,
quoting Ignatieff it now, "The
very notion of sacrifice in
battle has become implausible
or ironic." This is what
people are writing back
in the 1990s.
In war as spectacle, force had
acquired a symbolic value.
The aim was no longer anything
so crude as laying waste to
the enemy, merely demonstrating
that one
possessed the ability
to do so was
itself expected to suffice.
To use force was to strike
a posture, to manipulate
perceptions, or to
send a message.
This image of war transformed
derived from but also seem to
validate, in some senses,
I think what
Google exists to do.
That is to say, it seemed to
validate a technology hyped
mood that prevailed during the
last decade of the 20th
century and persists into
the 21st century.
By common consent, the defining
characteristics of
this new age were speed,
control, and choice.
Information was, is empowering
the individual.
Information reduces the
prevalence of chance and
surprise and random
occurrences.
Henceforth, everything relevant
could be known and,
if known, could be taken
into account.
The expected result was to
lessen if not eliminate
uncertainty, risk, waste, and
error, and to produce quantum
improvements in efficiency
and effectiveness.
The potential for applying
information technology to
armed conflict, long viewed as
an area of human endeavor
especially fraught with
uncertainty, risk, waste, and
error, appeared particularly
promising.
Given access to sufficient
information, man could regain
control of war, arresting
its former
tendency to become total.
Henceforth, the theory went
swiftness, stealth, agility,
and precision would characterize
the operation of
major armies.
Economy, predictability, and
political relevance would
constitute the hallmarks of war
in the information age.
In short, by the dawn of the
21st century, the reigning
postulates of technology as
panacea had knocked away much
of the accumulated blood rust
sullying war's reputation.
Thus reimagined, armed conflict
regained an aesthetic
respectability that the
literary and artistic
interpreters of 20th century
military cataclysms were
thought to have demolished
once and for all.
In the right circumstances, for
the right cause, it now
turned out, war could actually
offer an attractive option,
cost effective, humane,
even thrilling.
This new aesthetic made it as
far as Baghdad in the spring
of 2003, and that
was about it.
The war inaugurated with
expectations of shock and awe
delivering a clean and quick
victory turned out to be not
all that different from any
other war worthy of the name,
ugly and dehumanizing.
Well what lessons did Americans
take from all that
our troops suffered and
inflicted on others in Iraq?
That war was irredeemably
brutal and a risky
proposition?
Not at all.
Instead, we persuaded ourselves
that missile firing
drones and skilled commandos
could soften the brutality and
mitigate the risk.
This new aesthetic contributed,
in turn, to an
appreciable boost in the
status of military
institutions and soldiers
themselves.
This is the fourth manifestation
of this new
American militarism.
Since the end of the Cold War,
opinion polls surveying public
attitudes towards national
institutions have regularly
ranked the armed forces first.
Americans fearful that the
rest of society may be
teetering on the brink of
moral collapse console
themselves with the thought that
the armed services remain
a repository of traditional
values, old fashioned virtue,
and competence.
Confidence in the military has
found expression in a tendency
to elevate the soldier to the
status of national icon, the
apotheosis of all that is
great and good about
contemporary America.
As a consequence, in public,
today, homage to those in
uniform has become obligatory.
The one unforgivable sin in our
politics is to be found
guilty of failing to
support the troops.
In the realm of partisan
politics, the political right
has shown considerable skill
in exploiting this dynamic,
shamelessly pandering to the
military and to those members
of the public laboring under
the misconception that the
armed services are under
siege from a rabidly
anti-military left.
In fact, the Democrat mainstream
has long since
purged itself of any dove-ish
inclinations.
"What's the point of having
this superb military that
you're always talking about,"
Madeleine Albright famously
demanded of General Colin
Powell, "if we can't use it?"
As Albright's question attests
and as Barack Obama's
inclination to use force has
affirmed, when it comes to
advocating the use of
force, Democrats can
be positively gung-ho.
Even among left-liberal
activists, the reflexive
anti-militarism of the 1960s
has given way to a more
nuanced view.
Progressives have come to
appreciate the potential for
using the armed services to
advance their own agenda.
Thus, the most persistent calls
for US intervention
abroad to relieve the plight
of the abused and the
persecuted tend to come
from the left.
Oblivious to the implications
of this creeping militarism,
Americans have, for the most
part, simply accepted it.
Indeed, in unexpected quarters,
they have embraced
it with an enthusiasm that is
nothing short of inexplicable.
If only by default, the nation's
status, as the
greatest military power the
world has ever seen, has come
to signify a cosmic verdict
of sorts, a compelling
affirmation of American
exceptionalism.
In fact, however, our present
day military ascendancy
represents something
quite different.
For all this, seeing armed
force at the preeminent
expression of state power and
military institutions as the
chief repositories of civic
virtue, the expectation that
revolutionary advances in
military technology might
offer a tidy solution to complex
problems, all of this
distorts, if it does not
altogether forfeit, important
elements of the American
birthright.
Recall that at the outset,
the New World--
as it was called back
when I was a kid--
was intended to be radically
and profoundly new.
The vision of freedom animating
the founders of 17th
century Anglo-America and of
the 18th century American
Republic distinguished their
purpose from that of the Old
World, which was constantly
embroiled in bloody disputes
over privilege and power.
Princes, armies, and perpetual
war defined Europe.
The absence of these things
was to provide a point of
departure for defining
America.
Determined to preserve their
freedom and their experiment
in popular self-government,
Americans knew instinctively
that militarism numbered as
perhaps the foremost threat to
their prospect of doing so.
Military power was poison, one
not without occasional
utility, but a poison all
the same and never
to be regarded otherwise.
In our time, oblivious to the
potential consequences, we
have lost sight of that truth.
We have chosen to marry the
means of the Old World to the
ends of the New, relying on
force and the threat of force
to spread the American
way of life.
Or, as my favorite writer, Max
Boot, has put it, quoting,
"Imposing the rule of law,
property rights, and other
guarantees at gunpoint, if
need be," end of quote.
Thus has the condition that
worried the sociologist C.
Wright Mills, back in the mid
'50s, come to pass in our day.
Whereas in earlier times,
Mills wrote, Americans
enviewed history as, quote, "a
peaceful continuum interrupted
by war," today, planning
and preparing and
waging war has become--
again, quoting Mills--
"The normal state and seemingly
permanent condition
of the United States."
And as Mills observed, nearly
half a century ago, the only
accepted plan for peace
is the loaded pistol.
And with that, I'll conclude.
And I look forward to any
comments or questions
that you may have.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BACEVICH: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I agree with every
single thing you just said.
But I suspect you may be
preaching to the choir.
What I'm really curious about
is what you encountered in
terms of an opposing viewpoint
to your book.
So, I listen to what you
say, and I'm like--
ANDREW BACEVICH: You mean, if
I were a critic of myself,
what would be the criticism
I would advance?
AUDIENCE: No, what have you
bumped into, in terms of
people saying your wrong?
Because I listened to everything
you've said.
And this makes perfect sense.
But clearly, not everyone
agrees.
ANDREW BACEVICH: I think the
people who disagree would say
the following.
This is a disguised call for
a return to isolationism.
This is somebody who believes
that the United States can
turn its back on the world and
still provide for the nation's
security and the well being
of the American people.
This is somebody who has not
learned the self-evident
lessons of World War II that
unless the United States
seizes the imperative of
exercising global leadership,
the rest of the world goes
to hell in a handbasket.
I think that would
be the response.
Now, my interpretation
of US history--
I think an unsentimental
interpretation of US history
and, in particular, of
US foreign policy--
would go like this.
We've never practiced
isolationism.
From the founding of the
Republic, from the moment that
we secured independence from
Great Britain, successive
generations of American leaders
have been engaged in
an effort to expand American
power and to increase American
prosperity.
And from time of achieving
independence until roughly
around the Vietnam
War, that effort
achieved monumental success.
When I was a kid, back in the
1950s, and I was taught about,
let's say, the incorporation
of North America into the
Republic, everything beyond the
initial 13 colonies, 13
states, I was basically taught
that that was part of a
domestic story.
It wasn't part of a
US foreign policy in the 19th
century was substantially
about acquiring additional
territory, which we did by
means fair and foul.
We bought it.
We took it.
We negotiated for it, whatever
was necessary.
If you look at what occurred
between, roughly, 1800 and
1945, we have a story whereby
the United States of America,
in this presumably mostly
isolationist period of time,
emerged as the most powerful and
the wealthiest country on
the face of the Earth, probably
the wealthiest
country in all of history.
A tribute to the success
achieved by a policy of
expansionism, not
of isolationism.
If you look at what's occurred
since 1945, we have attempted
to further expand this American
imperium and to
continue to enhance the
security, well being, and
prosperity of the
American people.
The difference between the
pre-1945 story and the
post-1945 story is in the
outcomes we have achieved,
and, in particular, the outcomes
that we have achieved
in this period of time where,
I am arguing, that we have
fallen victim of militarism.
If you look at the story of US
foreign policy since the end
of the Cold War, an effort at
least to preserve, if not to
continue to expand, the
American imperium.
It's a story, it seems to me, in
which there is no question
that we've expended
extraordinary resources.
Some people estimate that the
Iraq war, itself, will
ultimately cost something
like $4 to 6 trillion.
We've expended enormous
resources.
Our soldiers have made very
considerable sacrifices.
Well, I ask you, is the country
becoming more secure?
Is the world becoming
more stable?
Are the American people able
to share in ever greater
prosperity as a consequence
of our military exertions?
It seems to me to be patently
obvious that the answer is no.
So again, I'm setting aside,
actually, moral
considerations.
The Mexican war was a war of
aggression, but that's how we
got California.
I'm not keen to give
California back.
So setting aside moral
considerations, an expansion,
this strategy pursued over a
period of roughly a century
and a half, was manifestly
successful.
Perpetuating that strategy over
the past several decades
is producing quite different
and adverse results.
And so we ought to
think differently
about the way forward.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Actually, much of what
you said, as he said, it
sounds very sensible.
But two questions that I think
are really important, if you
have an answer.
First, let me give you some
background so you know where
I'm coming from in asking
these questions.
I was born in Germany, when
my family was living in
Dusseldorf, a city that my
father, while he was in the
artillery in World War II, had
been largely responsible for
destroying and then, as an
American diplomat, had been
assigned the task
of rebuilding.
And he always said he was just
as proud of having rebuilt it
as he was of having
destroyed it--
and for good reason.
We later lived in Berlin,
in the free part of
Berlin, West Berlin.
And West Berlin was free only
because there were British,
American, and French troops
sitting there, not necessarily
fighting, but willing to fight
if the Russians would come
through that wall.
Later, we moved to Ethiopia.
And as the Navy moved out of
[INAUDIBLE] and the Military
Assistance Corp came out of
the Ogaden and went other
places, the Cubans came in.
Everybody in the neighborhood
in which we lived, with the
exception of a few houses, were
slaughtered, were killed.
At the time, there were those
who argued that an American
force might have saved
hundreds of
thousands if not millions.
And if nothing else, it
would have kept the
Cubans out of there.
So the two questions I would
ask, given that background, if
we accept what you've
said, the first
question is, so what?
And the second one is, what
should we be doing instead?
ANDREW BACEVICH: Well, again,
we could argue about this.
The so what is--
my argument would be that an
over emphasis on military
power, exaggerated expectations
of what military
power can achieve are harming
the well being of our nation.
We are spending a lot
and getting little.
And I would argue that that's
been the case since the end of
the Cold War.
I hope nothing I said in my
presentation somehow suggested
that I'm sort of opposed to
the basic US posture,
post-1945, vis-a-vis
the Soviet Union.
I spent seven years of my living
in Germany, in the
United States Army.
I think that the strategy of
containment was basically a
sound strategy, that the policy
of containing the
Soviet Union, in the aftermath
of World War II was probably a
necessary mission.
But note that the only people
who proposed preventive war
against the Soviet Union,
we would view, in
retrospect, as lunatics.
Whereas we now live in
a time in which--
to my knowledge, I may
be wrong here--
nobody in the Obama
Administration has explicitly
abrogated the Bush Doctrine.
I think that's a big, big
deal, big change.
So that would be point
number one.
The unrealistic expectations of
what military power can do
and the recklessness with which
we use it don't serve
the nation's interest, don't
serve the interests, I think,
of stability more broadly.
Now with regard to the Cuba, I
don't know that much about.
I mean, I know the Cubans were
mucking around in Africa for a
period of time.
I have to say, at the present
moment, I'm not particularly
concerned about the aspirations
of the Cuban
regime, which seems to me that
the revolution is largely
failed and does not represent a
threat to anybody, as far as
I can tell.
There was one other point you
wanted me to make, and I can't
remember what it was.
AUDIENCE: What should we do?
It sounds almost like
what you said, it's
really the Bush Doctrine.
Let me go back to when
I was a kid.
When I was a kid in Berlin,
they used to tell us that,
even though we were kids,
we were important to the
protection of the city.
Because the problem was that
the Americans would never
fight over Berlin until the
Russians came in and shot us.
And as soon as the shot
us, that would be
the reason to fight.
ANDREW BACEVICH:
That's correct.
To some degree, the families
of service members or other
Americans serving the government
in Western Germany,
not simply West Berlin, were
basically hostages.
AUDIENCE: We there to be shot.
ANDREW BACEVICH: Well, you're
overstating it.
AUDIENCE: Overstating, but the
point was, in those days, the
statement was very clear.
We will not fight until
they shoot at you.
ANDREW BACEVICH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Whereas today, after
the Bush Doctrine-- which is
something I think is just
absolutely bizarre-- is we
will fight when we're in the
mood or when we're afraid that
they might shoot you.
ANDREW BACEVICH: Yeah, I think
you're making my case, here,
for part of the problem.
AUDIENCE: Is that the core?
ANDREW BACEVICH: Well, I
think it's part of it.
It's not the whole thing.
What should we do?
What's the problem?
I think another element of the
problem has to do with the
creation of the all volunteer
force in the wake of Vietnam,
which had the consequence of,
for all practical purposes,
abandoning a tradition of
the citizen soldier.
The most important wars in our
history, the most successful
wars in our history, were wars
fought by citizen soldiers,
not professional soldiers.
Citizen soldiers preserved
the Union.
Citizen soldiers constituted
the forces that went and
fought against Nazi
Germany and Japan.
Citizen soldiers constituted
the the war in Korea, which
was a war fought pursuant to
that strategy of containment,
vis-a-vis the Soviet Union.
After Vietnam, we abandoned
that tradition.
And we embraced the idea of
an all volunteer force.
And I think that, to me, it
becomes increasingly evident
that that produced deeply
unfortunate and, indeed,
pernicious consequences.
Certainly, we have forces today
that are enormously
competent, well-disciplined,
well-motivated units that
display real cohesion.
But they don't win.
We didn't win in Iraq.
We're not going to win in
Afghanistan by any sort of
traditional definition
of what victory is.
But because they exist at such
a distance to the rest of
American society, because the
American people are no longer
engaged in, seriously engaged
in, no longer have a stake in
the well being of US forces,
in essence, the state has
exerted control over
US forces.
And I think employs them
recklessly and foolishly.
And the state gets
away with it.
So what should be done?
We should examine whether
there's some possibility of
reconstituting the tradition
of the citizen soldier, in
some aspect, where our
definition of citizenship, in
some way, entails recognition
of an obligation of citizens
to contribute to the defense
of the country.
We can have a debate
on how to do that.
Does that mean we should draft
every 18-year-old male and
female in this country?
I don't think so, because we
don't need a military anywhere
near that large.
Should we perhaps continue to
consider the possibility of a
program of national service,
where every 18-year-old male
and female would be expected
to contribute some form of
service to nation, to community,
with some number of
them serving in the military?
Perhaps we could do that.
So I think part of the issue
here is to reconstitute a
definition of citizenship that
entails collective obligation.
We used to have that,
at least in theory.
Now we no longer have
that even in theory.
Is that a fair answer?
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: How do you think that
some new aspects of war,
asymmetrical warfare, non-state
actors, ideology's
role in conflict now.
How do you think that that
might be affecting our
mentality about war and, in some
ways, because we're maybe
still learning exactly how
to fight these conflicts?
What constitutes
a win in Iraq?
What would constitute a
win in Afghanistan?
Because we're not really sure
what a win is that we're just
throwing money at the
problem, maybe?
ANDREW BACEVICH: I'm no sure I
fully understand the question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What role do you think
how war has changed?
ANDREW BACEVICH: That's the way
I was going to interpret
the question.
And my answer would be,
it really hasn't.
The nature of war
is immutable.
Where, I would argue, we went
wrong-- and I was trying to
insert this notion
into the talk--
is, in the wake of the Cold War,
in the wake of Operation
Desert Storm, at a moment when
the country was deeply
enamored with the potential
of technology--
you're all in the technology
business, I understand that--
that at this particular moment,
Americans who were
interested in national security,
in war, people who
are very smart but should have
known better, they persuaded
themselves that technology had
the capability to change
fundamentally warfare.
And it was that expectation, I
think, that helped to lay the
foundation for the misguided
approach we took to
responding to 9/11.
It what was their expectations,
the expectations
of people like Donald Rumsfeld,
specifically, who
thought that invading Iraq would
produce a quick, easy,
cheap, decisive victory, but
instead embedded us in a
protracted, ugly, inconclusive
war against a nation that,
guess what, had no involvement
in the 9/11 attacks.
So I really don't think that war
has changed all that much.
I think one of the great
mistakes that we made was
thinking that technology had
changed it or was changing it
or could change it.
And this is not an argument
that says that, somehow,
technology is irrelevant to
the conduct of warfare.
Given the choice between going
to war with a muzzle loading
musket and an M-4 assault
rifle, I'll
take the M-4 any day.
I just think we need to be very
wary of the notion that
technology has a transformative
impact because
it doesn't.
I mean it's really worth
contemplating that our
adversaries in Iraq and, to some
degree, our adversaries
in Afghanistan have absolutely
given us fits in employing a
weapon that we choose to call
the improvised explosive
device, the IED, which is,
basically, a crudely
constructed, home-made mine
that some people have
calculated you can make for
about the cost of a pizza pie.
And yet we have spent billions
of dollars trying to figure
out how to respond to the
threat posed by the IED.
And the IED has inflicted
unspeakable casualties on our
soldiers, despite the fact that
they have, presumably, a
great technological advantage.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So as of right now,
the US represents about 20% of
the world's GDP, over half
of the military spending.
We are in serious debt.
And considering the history of
the Roman Empire, the Soviet
Union, how does go unnoticed
by the top generals?
I cannot imagine how they sit
there, look at this, and they
think, you know what, this
is the right strategy.
We do need 12 carriers.
We do need stealth bombers.
How does that logic work?
How do they internalize it?
ANDREW BACEVICH: How
the hell do I know?
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BACEVICH: Seriously,
Admiral Mullen, who was the
Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff once removed, said,
while he was still on active
duty, that the greatest threat
to US national security
was the debt.
He said that publicly
in a speech.
Attracted a certain amount
of press attention.
And then, I think, basically
let that thought drop.
He didn't come back, two weeks
later and say, and here's what
we in the military propose
to do about that debt.
And my point there would be,
I think, at least in some
quarters in the senior military
leadership, there's
some awareness that this fiscal
overextension is a big deal.
And yet, one senses that--
and I'm just speculating now--
at the end of the day,
bureaucratic interests end up
trumping those insights.
The Pentagon itself, as a
powerful entity within the
federal government, the services
as a sub-set of the
Pentagon, for bureaucratic
reasons, they're all committed
to the proposition that they
want to sustain and, if
possible, not only increase
the size of the pie but
increase their chunk
of the pie.
Right now, my old service, the
United States Army, my sense
is, at least, that the Army is
deeply concerned that the
Obama administration's so-called
pivot towards
East-Asia--
whatever that means--
probably means that the Air
Force and the Navy are going
to be in a position to argue for
more money than the Army
is going to get.
Or to put it another way, after
Iraq and Afghanistan, if
somebody says, please explain
to me why the United States
Army exists?
The Army has a hard time
answering the question.
So I don't think you can
underestimate the importance
of bureaucratic politics would
be one of my answers.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned a
little bit about bringing back
the concept of the citizen
soldier and having national
service for all, some military,
some non-military.
I think after that, I'd like
to hear a little bit more
about how you think that
could be implemented.
And one other question is, you
mentioned and cited some stats
around how we have a larger
and more powerful standing
army relative to threats that we
have today than at any time
in our history.
But when World War II came
around and the Vietnam War, we
were putting out a flying
fortress every 100 minutes
from the factory.
With today's technology and the
training that's required
today of our soldiers, do you
think that it's feasible to
have fewer troops and less
machinery and to be able to
scale up as we [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW BACEVICH: I think that's
a great question.
So let's pretend we have a
force that is a citizen
soldier force in which,
presumably, young people would
come on active duty for
something like a couple of
years and that's it, right?
Then they have to go back.
They want to go to school.
They want to go on
to their career.
Can we train somebody to fly an
F-35, train them and then
commit them to the force such
that, given a two year period
of service, we're kind of
getting our money's worth?
And the answer is probably no.
There would certainly be certain
specialized functions
where you would want to recruit
long service people.
That said, I think service in
the infantry, crewing an
armored vehicle, being an
artillery man, crewing various
specialties, and crewing
warships, driving trucks,
maintenance functions, you
probably could train people
within a period of four, six,
eight months and, therefore,
still get a pretty substantial
amount of benefit after they
leave their training
and are serving in
the field as it were.
So you have to discriminate,
it seems to me.
And those things where
the citizen soldier
would be a good fit.
And other more complex, more
specialized functions where
you wouldn't.
And I think you could
figure that out.
But your first question,
how would you
sell national service?
I think it would be
a tough sell.
Because you're going to have
to be able to persuade the
nation's 18-year-olds and the
parents of the nation's
18-year-olds to participate in
this program to generate
sufficient grassroots political
support that the
necessary legislation could
be passed and implemented.
And I wouldn't for a second,
want to tell you I think that
would be easy.
I don't think it would be.
And the way to get it, I think,
would be to identify
someone in Washington in a
position of significant
influence who could champion
this kind of a cause.
I don't know who
that would be.
I, myself, when Senator Webb was
elected to the Senate from
Virginia, I kind of fancied for
a time that he might be a
strong, independent, critical
voice who would be able to
raise first order issues about
national security policy and
perhaps promote a debate.
It turned out, he
didn't do that.
And after a single term,
he left office.
I don't know what he's doing.
But we need a champion.
And maybe the comparison would
be the way Senator Ted Kennedy
was the champion for health
care reform for decades.
Indeed, he didn't even live
to see the success of his
enterprise.
But he promoted an idea
and stuck with it.
And eventually, the idea jelled
and gained enough
support that it became
reality.
Something of the same
would have to occur.
And I don't want
to minimize the
likelihood of that happening.
It's probably not very great.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What are your thoughts
on the existence of
what's been called a deep state
that essentially drives
the military industrial complex
forward and leads us
to these neverending wars?
Something like Operation Gladio,
as we saw in Italy and
Turkey in the '60s and '70s,
where this strategy of tension
has transformed into
a war of terror.
Do you believe that something
like that may be going on?
ANDREW BACEVICH: My view's
probably not as dark as I
think yours is.
But there are structural
explanations.
We don't have to go as
far as deep state.
All we have to do is look at
President Eisenhower's
farewell address in which he
warned of the dangers of a
military industrial complex.
There is a military industrial
complex.
As I suggested a couple of
minutes ago, there is a
national security apparatus that
is large and is powerful
and has interests that may not
necessarily coincide with the
interests of the
nation itself.
So I think there are structural
explanations that
need to be taken into account.
I don't think that somehow it is
that these structures, the
national security state,
provide an adequate, a
complete understanding of why we
do what we do and why we've
come to have the view
of military power
that we come to have.
I think you have to take into
account ideology, our
self-identity, our sense of the
role that we are called
upon to play in the world that
makes us as citizens
susceptible to manipulation by
people or institutions that
may have a self-interested
agenda.
So I'm not willing to simply
blame it all on the military
industrial complex.
I blame some of it on them.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk
somewhat about--
there's been a tendency over
the last decade by people
whose primary concern is
humanitarian, to want
intervention to effectively
rescue people.
We find ourselves taking sides
in Somalia or being told that
we should have intervened in
Rwanda, and that it's a
disgrace that we didn't.
You have the Mali situation.
So do you think that gives any
momentum to militarism?
ANDREW BACEVICH: Yeah, I tried
to suggest that in the talk.
I think it is.
I think that there are people,
who style themselves as
progressives or left-liberals
who, back in the 1960s, would
have viewed the military as the
opposition to some degree
now view military power as an
instrument that we, the
nation, can put to work
to do good deeds or
to rescue the oppressed.
There's a considerable debate
on right now suggesting that
the United States should,
somehow or other, intervene in
the Syrian civil war, not
necessarily directly by
putting US forces on the ground,
but by establishing,
for example, no fly zones.
That's part of the equation.
AUDIENCE: So what would
be your take on this?
That war is so destructive and
chaotic that that's not
[INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW BACEVICH: No, my
take would be the
following, I think.
Let's take the Syria case.
There is a civil war.
The civil war is leading to a
very substantial number of
Syrian non-combatants fleeing
their country.
They're going to Turkey.
They're going to Jordan,
primarily.
I think some are going
to Iraq, even.
And so the argument would be,
well, how can we stand by and
let that happen?
And my first question would be,
OK, well, let's take the
obligation to respond to
their plight seriously.
Why does it follow that the
appropriate way to respond to
their plight is to intervene
militarily?
I don't know what
the numbers are.
Let us imagine there is 100,000
Syrians living in
terrible refugee camps
in Turkey.
Why don't we bring
them to America.
And we'll offer them refuge.
That would certainly take
them out of harm's way.
So I don't know that necessarily
the appropriate
response to a humanitarian
problem is sending US forces.
Maybe there are non-military
ways to express the plight of
the people.
If we would say, no, no, no,
no, we need to intervene
militarily, we need to involve
ourselves militarily in the
Syrian civil war, then I think
I would say to the people who
propose that, how much are
you willing to pay?
Because it ain't free.
Are you willing to
raise your taxes?
Are you willing to accept the
reduction in the entitlements
you get from the government?
Are you willing to send your
kid down to the local
recruiter to go sign up
to fight on behalf
of the Syrian people?
Or to people who propose this,
are you simply asking the
American military to do
something so that you can
sleep better at night?
And if they say,
well, yes, yes.
I'm willing to raise my taxes.
I'm willing to reduce
my Medicare.
I'm willing to send my
kid to go fight.
Then I think the other question
I'd say to the
advocate of humanitarian
intervention is, tell me what
you think you're going
to get done.
Let's be realistic about
what we can achieve.
I dare say it is possible for us
to use our forces to put an
end to the civil war in Syria.
There's no question in my mind
that we can overthrow the
Assad regime.
But what are you going
to get then?
How long are you
going to stay?
Because there's some
considerable likelihood that
we won't like what follows the
Assad regime anymore than we
like the Assad regime.
And, in that sense, what
did you achieve?
So truly, it's not that I am
hard and fast against using US
forces for humanitarian
purposes.
I just think that, when that
subject comes up, there are a
whole host of questions that
ought to be addressed candidly
and honestly before we decide
that it's time to dispatch the
82nd Airborne to some distant
country and involve itself in
some complex situation.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: I wonder from the
perspective of those who are
still active duty, how
they would respond to
hearing your comments.
And so I have a two
part question.
One is, when did you start
thinking about these types of
issues and did you think about
them as far back as when you
were starting out
as an officer?
Did people talk about
it back then?
And how do we have this
intelligent, thoughtful
discussion about where our
country goes from here, which
you are leading the charge
on, without demotivating
especially our enlisted, those
who are coming on board with
these high hopes of representing
their country on
the front lines?
ANDREW BACEVICH: Well, the
generation when I was raised
as a young soldier, it was made
clear to me that soldiers
are instruments of the state.
Soldiers don't have politics,
shouldn't have politics.
And again, I was commissioned at
a time when the Vietnam War
was an ongoing proposition and
had deeply divided the
country, when many Americans,
as a consequence of Vietnam
and other things going in the
country, had very strong
political opinions on one
side or the other.
I was educated to understand
that that wasn't my business.
And I continue to believe that,
as difficult as it may
be, that that's the proper
position for
a soldier to take.
The principle of civilian
control means that people up
top, civilians, the civilian
leaders that citizens elect,
they are the ones who have to
deal with these very difficult
policy issues.
The obligation of the soldier
is to simply implement those
decisions once they are made.
If a soldier cannot in good
conscience do that, then the
soldier is in the wrong
line of work.
For example, at BU we got--
there aren't too many
universities that have Army
ROTC, Navy ROTC, and
Air Force ROTC.
We got all three services.
And I get a considerable
number of ROTC
cadets in my courses.
And I think about the difficulty
that they have.
Because in their ROTC training,
they are basically
being told that they are
instruments of the state and
that their job is to implement
orders, not question orders.
On the other hand, they come
into my classroom and I don't
view them as ROTC cadets.
I view them as young Boston
University undergraduates,
people who are becoming mature
adults and citizens.
And I want them to be able
to think critically.
And I sort of recognize that I
might be putting them in a
tough spot.
On the one hand, they're being
told that their job is to
follow orders.
And the other hand, I'm
telling them that
their job is to think.
So I think it's a problematic
thing.
And well, I'll just
leave it at that.
But it's funny when you say,
what do they think?
I have been struck and, indeed,
frankly heartened by
the number of emails, mostly,
that I'm getting from serving
military people, usually young
officers, people I've never
met, who tell me that they read
some things that I write
and that it helps them think
about their profession, think
about the role that the United
States plays, think about the
wars in which they themselves
have participated.
Now, it's a self-selected
group.
There's probably a much larger
number of people
who think I'm a jerk.
And fortunately, not too many
of them send me emails.
But I find it heartening that,
at least, there is some
audience in the active duty
community that seems to be
somewhat interested.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So I commend you for
your views and the way you
look at a problem.
But having read Lawrence
Lessig's book on the influence
of money in Washington and the
effects that it has on the
society thereof, isn't the
problem that you described
actually easier to solve not
by, I don't know, doing a
general draft or something,
but really to solving the
issue of how money influences
the decisions that are done in
Washington?
ANDREW BACEVICH: I agree
with the notion that
money plays a big role.
We alluded a little
while ago to the
military industrial complex.
And many of you know that, I
think, Eisenhower considered
actually referring in his
speech to the military
industrial congressional complex
because the money
lubricates politics.
But I'll be darned if I can
tell you how to fix that.
How do we get money out of?
You're not going
to get it out.
But how do we reduce the
significance of money in politics?
That's way beyond my brief.
And I'd love to see somebody
come up with an idea
about how to do it.
But, boy, I don't know.
How would you do it?
AUDIENCE: Well, Lawrence
Lessig [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BACEVICH: I haven't read
that book, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's Republic
Lost, I believe is the the
title of the book.
He has some actually practical
advice on how to move there.
ANDREW BACEVICH: I'll
look at it.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: You preempted a lot
of the questions I was going
to ask about our voluntary
military force.
So let me ask you a slightly
different question.
So I'm sure I'm not the only
one that holds this view.
But it certainly seemed like, in
the run-up to the invasion
of Iraq, that the game was a
little bit ginned, in the
sense that the press didn't
fulfill its role as being
objective about what
the merits were.
And I'm wondering, in the
current debate, about
situations that are in front of
us now like, for example,
Iran, whether you think
that there's been any
improvement at all?
And whether the debate now and
what's said in the press and
the questions that are being
asked are better or more
penetrating or lead
to a more open
debate then what happened?
ANDREW BACEVICH: Yeah,
not particularly.
I mean I share your view of the
overall tone of reporting
in the run-up to the
invasion of Iraq.
And from my perspective, part
of the problem was that
mainstream media had fallen prey
to this false notion of
what war had become.
They bought into the shock
and awe notion.
I do think that the
reporting during--
we're talking about
Iraq here--
parts of the insurgency
was much better.
It was more balanced, more
critical, appropriately so.
But to tell you the truth, I
think that the press then fell
for the whole Petraeus, surge,
counter insurgency, turn the
war around, greatest general
since Patton argument in ways
that, in a sense, replicated
their failure in the first
stages, that now COIN, as they
called it, became the new
American way of war.
So at best, I think the
reporting has been mixed.
And it's not clear to me that
they learned a lot.
AUDIENCE: We've got room for
one more [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BACEVICH: Well, you've
been raising your hand.
So why don't you do
the last question?
AUDIENCE: My question would be,
what do you think about
Bill Lynn's hypothesis that what
we really need to worry
about is order.
And if we're not careful, we
make the world a lot worse
place rather than a lot better
place by throwing around
power, because we can create
more terrorists than we can
possibly kill.
ANDREW BACEVICH: I
think he's right.
Again, I think that's
self-evident.
Justine is going to get tired
of hearing me say this,
because I said it in
the breakfast talk.
If I were telling the story of
US military history, over the
past 30 or so years, now, I
would begin it with the
promulgation of the Carter
Doctrine in January of 1980.
That was when President Carter
said, the Persian Gulf is a
vital national security interest
of the United States.
We'll use all means necessary,
to include military force, to
prevent bad guys from
taking it over.
And I think what Carter
inadvertently did was to set
in motion a project, a project
that has grown in scope and,
in many respects, has grown in
intensity over time, in which
US policymakers have acted on
the presumption that the
application of American hard
power to that region of the
world is going to
bring stability.
Now when Carter was talking,
he was talking about the
rather specific Persian Gulf.
I think that, over the course
of 30 years, the
implementation has been over
what we now call the greater
Middle East.
If we simply try hard enough,
we're going to be able to
stabilize that region.
And then the benefits
will be great.
Well if you step back at 2013
and now look at all the things
that we've done since 1980, from
a military perspective,
in the greater Middle East, ask
yourself if that region of
the world is becoming
more stable?
And the answer is
no, it's not.
It's becoming less stable.
Now, I'm not sure it's become
less stable because of the way
we have used our forces,
although that's possible.
It could be it's become less
stable for reasons that
basically we have
no control over.
But regardless, simply trying
harder, simply trying to
devise new ways of using
American hard power-- that's
what Obama's been doing with
these drone strikes--
I see no indication that trying
harder is going to give
us a different result.
And that, therefore, it's time
to ask some very difficult,
uncomfortable questions about
US policy in the region.
And that's a debate that I think
few people in Washington
are willing to undertake.
And it's a debate that people
who favor this emphasis on
military power are absolutely
opposed to.
Hey, this has been
a lot of fun.
I really appreciate you
turning out and
listening to this.
[APPLAUSE]